i'm not a good person well whatever
you're fine
i killed a kid
[Music]
it's not a unique insight but sometimes
when you say the unsavable thing you
realize it wasn't that unstable sounds
like the story of a hero to me i would
have been straight out of there
serious i would have been out of that
water like a tabby cat out of a bath
don't man jokes often bring a new way of
looking at things and it seemed true and
right that quite quickly that someone
like roman starts making jokes and
there's something terrible about that
but there's something liberating as well
i guess i'm just trying to say like
who's the real victim here i waited
three quarters of an hour for a gin and
tonic
kendall sees the it's not something
that's the end some things will continue
including a relationship and even love
from his siblings
so we go see him and we tell him we just
won't have it right
roman has the most difficult decision
because his position through the season
has changed and the way he feels valued
by his dad has changed you know
kendall's already declared as an
antagonist shiv finds that's how she
feels when the prospect of losing the
company arises you think daddy's
protecting you
no we let matson take control that is
dad slamming the door it means that he
doesn't ever think that we will can or
should take over
time to rip off the band-aid there's
always been the feeling of what if we
could all go in and fire the water
pistol together if we could all say the
same thing at once what would happen
it's an exhilarating power and it's
quite intoxicating we can fight it out
it'll it'll be fun
that will be fun
if i look at the arc of this season from
the chaos at the end of episode two [ __ ]
you plastic jesus you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
save the planet ken
you're a [ __ ] prick and there we are
episode nine and the siblings however
damaged found their way back together
for the first time really since their
teenage years i think
turn them in
come on come on come on i came into the
scene really anxious to find our way
through these pivotal moments of uh the
first one for me where roman is having
to face the dragon to face his father
can you take him out romulus and to
stand up to his father which of course
he palpably failed to do if we look back
at season one episode six you better be
smelling your [ __ ] armpit romulus
there's a question about why you know
when in the first season he wasn't able
to raise his hand and why is he able to
now roman i thought we had to figure it
out
yeah it just might be better you know if
we all here some people would see growth
i'm on the fence about human beings and
people certainly change what they do but
in my view people's essential selves
don't change in a way that's what makes
drama and choices interesting i've got
you come on let's discuss so i would say
that the circumstances around roman have
changed this is an opportunity sir he
feels this weight of support that makes
it possible for him to be a full sibling
you can trust me you can't trust him
it's a superpower that logan has to be
able to lie to people's faces and then
if people have the power to make him
come good on those promises then he will
and if they don't then they're in a new
situation and they'll have to be a new
accommodation fan we can stop you
you're playing toy [ __ ] soldiers
i have you beat
do you want a deal with the devil the
implication is that tom is the one who
blew the whistle on the kids and enabled
logan to secure the deal which they
could have stymied caroline you're on
tom's been on his way to making this
kind of choice
for a long time unconsciously
since shiv's
admission on their wedding night that
she'd had an affair since a few nights
before that when she said that she
doesn't love him i think he does love
her quite passionately and she after her
own fashion
loves him but there are a lot of caveats
for both of them if you're being
generous to them their relationship is
very complicated we're going to force
him out where do i fit in chef well high
up tom i don't know he's a realist and a
romantic of one of the incredible kind
of beautiful complications about tom so
it was kind of inevitable at some point
that he would put self before her other
people who are in the family will always
be a roy will always be in the
newspapers but tom maybe has a certain
cold calculation to make about what he
needs to give if he's going to stay in
that world hey for a long time i
couldn't find the ending and then we did
a take where we gave sarah's character
time to process that moment you should
have trusted me and when tom walked over
and said you okay
despite that absolutely extraordinary
betrayal she put a game face on and said
yep yeah and because it was such a
perfect kind of succession moment that
she would still somehow find the
strength to put that kind of teflon coat
on and be in denial of that pain was so
powerful to me that i knew we had the
end of the season
you